what's up everybody today we are here
with the champ
the champ is in the building and the
squad do you got the headphones on or
are we on speaker
now you got the headphones yeah man we
here we here we live okay okay
first of all congratulations
congratulations sexy
i love it you know what i mean we do we
we got to get we got to get to the
bottom of something real quick you would
mention in the pre-fight hype this is
izzy israel style vendor okay
we got the [ __ ] ufc champion
the goat okay now
you said in the pre-fight hike you said
that uh
that victory was going to be gas right
and you said that
he was going to be breathing out of his
mouth and uh
there was a point in the fight where he
was bent over and you opened up uh his
butthole
was that so you could help him get more
oxygen in his body
yeah i mean he was gassing down so i had
to let the gas out somehow
he was facts though he was easy did you
think the fight was easier than uh
you expected uh
yep it was but um for me i you know you
know i am i'm hard on myself i felt like
i was having fun out there there was
even a point my my coach had to pull me
back a little bit because i thought to
get over excited
and told me like just chill i think my
coaches had ptsd from the last fight
because when i got
when i knew he was tired i was gonna put
him away he shot in but i knew this guy
wasn't
he wasn't gonna keep me down he's trying
to keep me down so
my conscience just told me to pull back
a little bit um but i mean
me i had point out this the first time
i've had fun out there for a long time
where i was playing around you know he
was trying to be boring i was still
you know counting him making the crowd
entertained um i haven't done that
so it was kind of nice to do that last
night yeah man it was it was great to
see man it looked like you were having
fun out there
and uh it was cool honestly it was cool
seeing
him him almost like get you in that rear
naked choke
yeah yeah because i was not threatened
at all
yeah yeah you didn't you didn't look
threatened but for a moment i was like
oh [ __ ] here it is
here's what's gonna happen because this
is what i figured everybody in your
division was gonna try to do they're
like all right bet
we just get them on the ground and then
once it's on the ground we could take
over
and do you think that that narrative is
done
um i don't think so i think they're
still going to keep hoping but for me
honestly man
like i remember that moment and it's all
the work i've been doing with my breath
my breath coach my performance coach
because um kai was in a similar
situation in our last fight at the apex
and he said all that work on the water
made him calm so even when i was in that
position i was not threatened i didn't
panic not even my heart didn't skip a
beat
i was calm and then i held it and i
reversed it straight away and i put him
i got him like that you know
you know what i'm talking about you know
when you're in the very like
the xn xxx [ __ ] you know i like it i saw
this look in his eyes
and he was just like horny [ __ ] i
said to him i swear i want
no hey he didn't want it for me trust me
but i said to him with the words i said
to me like you're scared aren't you
you're scared aren't you i said that to
him i can see you look in his eyes and i
try to elbow him and i just missed and i
just missed but
yeah i like that look in a man's eyes
when you go down by this and you're
looking in the eyes and he's scared for
his [ __ ] life
play fast forward whatever you want to
do with that all of it
do you think he was scared
yes oh no i saw it in his eyes because
that was his hope he thought
he probably got hard thinking like yes
this is it i finally have the back i can
choke him out
he's got nothing and i just easily
turned him around and i just
i dominated him so yeah um
yeah he was scared i saw it in his eyes
all right we got to talk about something
that happened for the pre-fight hype you
had one of the best pre-fight hype posts
i've ever seen right where you let the
[ __ ] snake out yeah okay
now i gotta i gotta experience i got a
serious question about this i need you
to be 100 honest with us you're on
flagrant two right now
did you warm up the piece did you warm
up the piece before you put it out there
never like i mean how can i warm up the
piece when something there's like so
many people around and also
you gotta understand it's [ __ ] i
don't know how many degrees it is out
here we're in the desert man
right in the desert you know the thing
thing the thing thingy when it's
when it's hot out in the street so yeah
it was just it's one of those days man
it's one of those days that just
happens you gotta let it hang out okay
it was a heavy day
yo so what's next man when you come in
new york first of all stop [ __ ]
around out there on the west coast
i met i was supposed to come to new york
i was supposed to stay in the states
i couldn't get my 01 visa in time for
the work we were going to do so
um it fell through so now i got to go
back home but i was my plan was if you
guys was in miami i wanted like a
a grand return back to the flagrant 2
army because
i felt like i was there since a dark fan
and i came to the studio in new york
and i felt like it would be cool to
return rather than zoom or skype to
return like
you know in the flesh yeah triumphant as
as a champ you know so
don't worry i mean the emails are leaked
now
you know the vaccines are out everyone
knows what's up so
yeah shit's about to hey shit's about to
blow over soon and then like i can roll
around these
these streets again if you will let's go
man yo what's your deadline we're going
to work this out
jewish bro he can make this happen i'll
leave tomorrow that's the problem
i'm already scheduled to leave tomorrow
it's already out the way so we can't do
it anymore boy it's all right i mean
these things pass
you know life happens and i feel like
another opportunity will come up
i mean they're definitely gonna do a
another one so yeah
on the next one probably we'll do it
together all right
well absolutely we're looking we're
looking forward to that but seriously
next time you get in some trouble with
that should you holler at me we'll work
it out we got some connections over
there
i don't know man you know some people i
bet that say less
we know some people yo yo um i think you
retired paul acosta yo
when you [ __ ] his ass in a few days
man
hey man he's doing a few days so um i
think you retired him yeah
uh hold up i think hold up someone just
spun out
oh [ __ ] wait let me see who's pointing
out hold on can i flip this can i put
this damn i can't flip it oh i can't
now we're just watching someone spin out
it was a red car because they were
racing my boys are racing right now
someone spawned out and i heard
everybody
go oh [ __ ] wait is that
you regained his control yo hey ass oh
you're backing
up on your
[Music]
[Applause]
building what's up boy hi
i'm good i'm good i'm good bro i've said
that line once a month
ever since i left you
i asked everybody to everybody listening
right now
as we're drunk in a bar somewhere in
australia maybe what was it perth or
some [ __ ] right
and i go what do you say allegedly
allegedly allegedly i go what do you say
to like an australian girl you know like
to get her like horny or whatever like
that
and he goes oh all right mate you can
use my line i go what's up he goes he
goes
you just you just look at them right in
their face and you say on your back and
wet up
give her a vb and tell her to get on her
back and went off
works every time
all right ass we can't we can't hear you
got to take off the headphone bro we
can't hear you
good i'll go back i'll talk to you but
you can't hear me okay wait can you hear
him now i can hear her now i can hear a
little better yeah yeah
yeah yeah anyway that's good
he got nervous easy i love that guy man
it was so funny
um yo is man we don't want to take up
too much of your time man but we're
proud of you bro
it's great to see you through his ass
and i mean this sincerely
wow i don't think paul acosta wants to
fight no more man
i think i think you i think you beat him
in a way where he goes the only way i'll
do this
like i'm not doing this for love no more
i'm doing this for money
yeah i mean um when you have a lot of
yes man like i read these people like
coloring books man i get so easy
when you have a lot of yes men around
you blowing smoke up your ass
every day telling you you're the
greatest you know it was kind of similar
to this fight
you know i just i i smell the [ __ ]
and i was like
this is this is this is a guy who gets
blown up every day man his ego was
blowing
one thing i loved was when i when i
dropped it because the arena was so
silent
because if you listen closely you hear
the panic in this corner
there was a guy screaming like oh no my
boy got drunk
he had the streak in his voice and that
that was like
and like i felt like that took away from
him and i took his manhood away so i
mean
you can't come back from that and then
he had all these excuses and then you
know i'd be
fine i think you should go into the wine
making business you'll actually be
successful at that he's already got the
tagline
yeah make some wine
[Laughter]
um all right so what's next man you
calling out robert whittaker like
does do you really get motivated for
that fight like you are you destroyed
the guy
yeah um i do because he he's a beast but
um
i feel like it has to be in auckland but
because of this whole [ __ ] right now
it might not be an often but i will
i can get myself up you know me i get
myself up for anything
because you know the fight i want to see
yeah
which one you know i want you know i
want to see you go at it with darren
till i don't even care if you guys fight
but i just want to see the instagram
build
up i'll tell you one thing there's a new
season of tough with
my boy alex volkanovski coaching it
watch that it's gonna be dope
it's it's already i think episode three
is coming out this week um
they did breaking news leaked it got it
got offered to me
and darren tilbury and instantly i said
no because
personally i don't want cameras in my
face that much and i don't want to be
stuck in vegas for that long i just feel
like
i mean what does it take to make good
reality tv drama a lot of drama
and i'm in trouble i feel like
it would i would have to you know go to
the lowest
form of my decline sorry
i got a call my bad my man i got a call
um but i felt like i would have to go to
the lowest
form of myself to to create
all the pranks that would yeah the
pranks that would play i would
i can go lower like people don't
understand like i i mean i take the high
when it's time to go low limbo limbo
[Laughter]
well listen man we love you bro we
appreciate you we'll see you in new york
soon
uh get your ass back here man we gotta
hang already
well definitely get some petrol let's go
around
some night clubs i love you boo why you
looking nice today by the way tell alex
what's his name uh what's his name he
was looking at you all crazy next time i
see him i might have to slap him
alex jones alex jones or dylan yeah he
was looking at you all crazy i had to
tell him no alex jones oh yeah yeah i'm
gonna back the [ __ ] up
all right you could get the chance
sooner yeah yeah yeah
i might have might happen sooner
hey you've been gone too long i'm
forgetting about you bro you gotta come
back here man
if i'm coming back i'm coming back i'm
gonna claim that thorn again
let's go all right homie be good
love you guys see you guys later bro